wow hier am Tisch tut ja schon ganz viel
bitte berichten Sie mich ein falsches
sie verzichten auf Fleisch verzichten
auf Flugreisen und sie haben heute Abend
auch die These mitgebracht warum es
gerade wichtig ist und die wollen wir
uns auch gerne anhören von Ihnen gerne
wenn ich aber dürfen Sie gerne vorher
noch mal darauf eingehen weil ich finde
dein Punkt extrem spannend dass du sagst
eben wir alleine können das nicht machen
genau das stimmt so wir müssen
tatsächlich für eins für einen handeln
damit wir so etwas machen können aber
trotzdem würde ich gerne ein bisschen
mit diesem Mythos von Deutschland als
Spitzenreiter des Klima des
Klimaschutzes brechen weil das was halt
nicht worüber nicht gesprochen wird und
da sehe ich das Problem ein bisschen wie
über klimaaktivismus gesprochen wird in
Medien in Gesellschaft ist das nur über
die Form gesprochen wird oh das ist
irgendwie undemokratisch oh da hat
irgendwie jemand Suppe geschmissen
anstatt dass wir uns tatsächlich mal
ordentlich anschauen worüber sollen wir
denn eigentlich sprechen worüber
sprechen denn die klimaaktivistinnen und
da wirklich dann den Fokus drauf legen
und da muss ich dann auch ein bisschen
auf die Firma klopfen zu sagen
Deutschland als als Spitzenreiter im
Klimaschutz einer oder
das größte Gas und Öl unter nur
Unternehmen Deutschlands wintersaal
betreibt franking in Argentinien
vertreibt indigene Menschen in Russland
von ihren Territorien das ist nicht
unbedingt vor eine spitzenrolle im
Klimaschutz sein das Deutschland hat
eine extrem große Rolle wir haben das
Braunkohle Revier im Westen im Westen
Deutschlands es stimmt davon nicht dass
Deutschland als Spitzenreiter im Klima
im Klimaschutz so da steht
kein Problem müssen wahrscheinlich ein
völlig anderes und da wagt sich keiner
ran auch in der un- keine ran 1,3
Milliarden chinesischen 1,3 Milliarden
in der 1,3 Milliarden Menschen in Afrika
ja wir bleiben die jetzt zukünftig mehr
an Energie verbrauchen ja
das verhindern wir doch nicht dadurch
dass wir in die industrialisieren
absolut auch Umwelttechnik
beispielsweise abbauen wir haben die
sicherste Atomkraftwerke wieder und das
schauen wir mal weg aber wir bleiben
einmal finde ich doch noch mal bei
Deutschland weil das ja immer debattiert
wird sind wir jetzt gut im Klimaschutz
oder nicht dass die anderen Länder wie
China schlechter sind ich denke da haben
wir alle eine Meinung auch sie
wahrscheinlich Frau Wagner würden mir
hier zustimmen das ist Länder gibt die
schlechte im Klimaschutz sind als wir
weiß ich gar nicht so ehrlich gesagt
weil Deutschland tatsächlich wirklich
einfach eine spitzenrolle für diesen in
diesen Hinsichten spielt wir müssen
einfach schauen auch wo kommen unsere
Kinder
über andere Länder gar nichts sagen
können wo die Produkte hergestellt
werden und für wen China für wen China
produziert wer kauft die Produkte von
China zum Beispiel mit wem hat China
Abkommen und es ist oft ein Manöver um
von den eigenen Verantwortungen
abzuwenden sagen aber China ist das
Problem und die ganze
überbevölkerungsthese das ist ein sehr
Problematik klare Frage wenn sie sagen
sie haben keine Ahnung wie es in den
anderen Ländern steht wir wollen sie
dann relatives Urteil fällen über die
das Niveau des Klimaschutzes oder des
Umweltschutzes in Deutschland das macht
doch nur Sinn wenn man in Relationen
sieht und ich glaube außer ihnen weiß
dass jeder dass das Hauptproblem
natürlich genau wie Herr krauses
geschildert hat nicht bei uns und auch
gar nicht in Europa liegt sondern das
ist natürlich in Asien liegt vor allen
Dingen in China produziert denn China
für wen produziert denn China
das ist ein interessanter Punkt weil das
zeigt was der eigentliche Angriffs
Angriffspunkt ist es ist ein Grunde
Antikapitalismus es geht gar nicht um
die Frage wer verschmutzt die Welt
sondern es geht um die Frage wie mit
wintersaal oder was auch immer wer
produziert was wo unter welchen
Bedingungen finde ich okay das ist eine
gute Frage das wäre auch eine
marxistische Frage ja denn das fehlt ja
der Linken dass sie mal wieder anknüpfen
findet an Marx oder an eine linke
Gesellschaftsanalyse aber das ganze wird
auch ganz anders abgedeckelt nämlich
über die Frage klimainitiative und das
sehe ich eben genauso wie Herr Kraus es
ist doch so dass wir wirklich in
unendlich vielen Dingen vorbildlich sind
vor allen Dingen dass unsere Regierung
die jetzt gerade dran ist
Klimaziele hat wie kaum ein anderes Land
ich selber könnte kein anderes Land
nehmen das ähnlich ambitionierte
Klimaziele hat und darüber hinaus ist es
auch so und dass ich den habe ich den
einzige Differenz zu Ihnen zu Ihrem
ich glaube nicht dass das Problem dieser
Aktivisten das ist dass sie provozieren
würden gegenüber der Regierung sondern
ganz im Gegenteil die Regierung wird
nicht unter Druck gesetzt die Regierung
wird nicht erpresst von den Aktivisten
ebenfalls bei uns in Deutschland sondern
es ist so dass die eine Speerspitze sind
sie sind die Avantgarde dessen wohin die
rot-grünen Politik eigentlich will und
das finde ich ist das Spannende an der
ganzen Sache die Aktivisten schneiden in
Butter bei uns in Deutschland sie haben
das schönste und einfachste Leben auf
der Welt weil alle es gut finden was sie
machen jedenfalls die die öffentliche
Meinung bestimmen und das ist finde das
ist das Problem dass ich während
versuchte anzusprechen es ist nicht so
dass das Protest ist der wenn man zu
will gegen die Gesellschaft gegen die
herrschende Politik ist im Gegenteil die
Politiker neigen immer mehr dazu
gewissermaßen in der ersten Reihe des
Protests mitzumarschieren ja und das
passiert auch de facto immer wieder ja
und ich meine das dann Frau Neubauer
selbstverständliche
Termine hat bei Herrn Lindner der
offenbar versucht sein
bei allen möglichen Leuten das ist ja
selbstverständlich also das passt so
wunderbar ins Bett
ganz ganz noch reinwerfen ich habe mir
auch noch mal die Parteiprogramme auch
generell angeschaut und alle Parteien
außerhalb der AFD wollen das Pariser
Klimaabkommen übererfüllen der Weg dahin
ist ein anderer die FDP sind eher auf
den technischen Fortschritt die andere
darauf Anpassung die anderen eher auch
verzichten aber alle Parteien außerhalb
der AFD wollen das Pariser Klimaabkommen
übererfüllen nur mit anderen Wegen da
habe ich mich dann auch gefragt die
Frage gerne an SIE Frau Wagner was die
denn dann also noch tun sollen weil das
Pariser Klimaabkommen wenn das schon
übererfüllt werden soll das ist ja genau
das was weltweit beschlossen wurde sie
sollen erstmal einfach tun
anstatt sich vorzunehmen immer nur mehr
zu tun mehr zu tun mehr zu tun weil
allein das Pariser Klimaabkommen die
Sachen die dort beschlossen sind sind ja
noch nicht mal umgesetzt worden im
Pariser Klimaabkommen zum Beispiel wurde
beschlossen mit 100 Milliarden das 100
Milliarden Dollar glaube ich war es die
Währung
verwendet werden soll um Ländern zu
ermöglichen sich an Klima an
Klimakatastrophen Umweltkatastrophen
anzupassen allein diese 100 Milliarden
pro Jahr sollten die bezahlt wurden die
sind nicht gezahlt worden aber jetzt
sind die Grünen ja sogar in der
Regierung aber trotzdem warten wir immer
noch seit 2015 darauf dass zum Beispiel
diese Maßnahme genommen getroffen wird
um Ländern zu helfen sich an die
Klimakatastrophe CO2 neutrale Atomkraft
weil wir dann immer noch im Problem des
uranextraktivismus sind und die Probleme
die die Atome die Anti-Atombewegung
damals vorgebracht hat immer noch weil
jede sind und das mit der Mythos der CO2
in Deutschland warum sieht der Rest der
Welt ist völlig anders der Rest der Welt
sieht es nicht unbedingt
die Länder die unseren Weg folgen es
gibt sie auch in Europa können Sie an
den Fingern ein einer Hand abzählen alle
anderen nicht nur in Frankreich Norwegen
alle möglichen anderen Länder entwickeln
super moderne neue Atomkraftwerke die
fast alle Gegenargumente die früher zur
gegen viele Atomkraftwerke nicht gegen
die Deutschen sondern viele gegen viele
andere beispielsweise Ukraine ins Feld
geführt wurden vollkommen Gegenstand so
es machen also die Frage ist doch in
vielen Fällen ist das übrigens ähnlich
in vielen anderen politischen Fällen
auch warum muss Deutschland eigentlich
immer vorangehen und steigt aus das ist
das Wort das ich in fast allen
Deutschland muss nicht führen
Deutschland wir können uns einfach auch
zusammenschließen und halt zusammen nur
zusammen wenn die Politiker die Politik
und die Bewegung die Gesellschaft sich
zusammenschließt können wir tatsächlich
auch was erreichen Deutschland
demokratische Entscheidungen akzeptieren
was eigentlich auch relativ sinnbefreit
ist weil man auf andere
[Musik]
Energieprinzip ansprechen Demokratie
funktioniert nach Gewaltenteilung ja
Exekutive Legislative Judikative wir
haben das ja nicht mehr
gesagt was die Koalition so beschließen
hat
das souverän ist ausgehebelt ja und die
Judikative wird ja auch im Grunde
genommen politisch besetzt wir brauchen
es nicht aufregen über politische
verfassungsgerechte
nennen ja wir brauchen für dich
aufzuregen über die Gerichtsbarkeit in
Polen und den Ungarn
ja
vergleichen wir sitzen im Glashaus was
die Rekrutierung von hohen Richtern in
Karlsruhe betrifft nein das ist die
Gewaltenteilung auf diesen drei Säulen
die nicht mehr funktioniert dann kommt
dazu als vierte Kraft die Presse die
vierte Gewalt und jetzt das ist meine
These mittlerweile das geht in die
Richtung von von Bolz haben wir die
fünfte Gewalt die NGOs die NGOs hinter
denen alle hinterher dackeln ja und die
das gut finden und wenn ich mir ein
Mitglied des NDR Rundfunkrates anschauen
auch dazu welches Mitglied eine grüne
Abgeordnete Name fällt man sich ein die
findet diese Tomatensuppen und was weiß
ich Aktion findet die als volle Kunst
also das ist für mich so ein simples
Beispiel wie mittlerweile die
klassischen drei Gewalten in dem Fall
Legislative exklusive hinter NGOs
direkt Frau Wagner ob die NGOs die
fünfte Gewalt sind im Staat wie sehen
Sie das haben sie so viel Macht
wir sehen das in der Klimabewegung oder
in der klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung nicht
ähnlich aber unter anderem Umständen
ähnlich nein tatsächlich nicht weil NGOs
eine Rolle spielen die wir nicht gerne
hätten dass sie spielen weil NGOs
tatsächlich in manchen Feldern zu viel
Macht einnehmen und in manchen
Situationen tatsächlich wieso
Aktivistin zur staatssekretieren
quasi-regierung fungieren die dann aber
ihre eigenen Politiken und ihre eigenen
Ideologien wieder einführen können in
Ländern in denen sie einfach nur ihre
Politiken implementieren und dadurch zum
Beispiel auch westliche Vorstellung von
Natur wie sagt man das Naturschutz
Naturschutz umsetzen können und dadurch
aber zum Beispiel aber auch wieder die
Bevölkerung von ihren Länder schreiben
können einfach nur weil sie die Macht
haben dass du ihre Ideologie
nicht alle sind durchaus ein Joos die
gute Arbeit leisten aber viele
machtvolle NGOs sind tatsächlich eher
ein Problem als zum Beispiel es ist eher
ein Problem Alter ist muss man ein
bisschen differenzierter sehen
Greenpeace spielt eine wichtige Rolle
und hat aber durchaus trotzdem auch die
Rolle als
interventionistische Bewegung sozusagen
anmacht durchaus auch verloren wer macht
die Politik noch mal die bärburg hat
sich die Chefin von Greenpeace als
Staatssekretärin ist Auswärtige Amt
geholt einmal nach was falsch ist an
Greenpeace da würde ich jetzt nicht ins
Detail reingehen das ist einfach wie
gesagt wie ich gesagt habe sie haben ein
Stück weit die macht auch einfach
verloren als tatsächlicher Intervention
in die Gesellschaft und wie viele NGs da
würde ich ein bisschen mitgehen dass
eine tatsächliche linke Kritik eine
Gesellschaftskritik oft in diesen NGOs
und dann in genau in den in den Chaos
vielleicht auch in vielen Teilen der
klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung fehlt es
fehlt eine Gesellschaftsanalyse die
Wirtschaft die die Wirtschaftsprobleme
mit in den Klimaschutz mit einem und das
ist genau etwas was wir in der in der
Gruppe die ich gerade repräsentiere
zumindest versuchen zu tun Herr Stöcke
gibt es irgendwelche NGOs die sie
unterstützen
also wenn ich das jetzt sage was ich die
ganzen wenn ich das jetzt sage was ich
jetzt im Kopf habe denn Lachen sich die
beiden Herren und du sich tot ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was NGOs sind
Organisationen ob ich welche unterstütze
Greenpeace
ich habe ganz überlegt Angie oh was ist
denn das jetzt ich mein Bär Entertainer
verstehst du kein Politiker muss ich
sowas wissen nee die Abkürzung muss man
nicht wissen
Leute weil guck mal welche überlege sie
war jetzt alles sehr kryptisch und unser
Publikum die haben sich vielleicht auch
gedacht
also du meinst diese Organisation die
viel Macht haben ob die viel Macht
auslösen und dadurch etwas
verändern ihr kann sein ich habe keine
Parteien Regierung sind sozusagen das
heißt
was ist denn noch ne nicht nicht
Dingsbums wie heißt das Wort
regierungsorganisieren
es gibt ganz viele ach die humana auch
oder bundesumwelthilfe und so weiter
ja ich habe nur gesehen ich habe mal bei
humana gelesen dass die mehr Geld
ausgeben für irgendwelche internen
Sachen als was sie wirklich für Spenden
und sowas benutzen
bekommen
ich bin aufgeklärt aber jetzt vielleicht
nicht in na ja jetzt auch noch bei NGOs
aufgeklärt und wir kommen jetzt zum
Thema machen wir das Lernen von Herrn
Bolz dürfte ich aber ich habe ja
eigentliche Gruppe die eigentliche Sache
ja noch gar nicht dargestellt vielleicht
darf ich dazu kommen noch gar nicht von
der Gruppe eigentlich gesprochen von der
ich eigentlich da bin und das ist der
vor climate also die Schulden Streichung
für Klimagerechtigkeit und das
eigentlich
finde ich das interessant weil die
eigentlich die Gruppe das ein bisschen
zusammenführt was sie eigentlich auch
gerade kritisieren so wir müssen eine
gesellschaftliche gesellschaftliche
Macht aufbauen sie haben in einer ihrer
ihrer Interviews tatsächlich auch gesagt
ihnen fehlt dieser great Reset von unten
sie haben ein bisschen eine Angst dass
der great Reset von oben gerade diktiert
und das ist eigentlich etwas was wir in
dieser dead for Climate Gruppe
anbieten sozusagen in great Reset
tatsächlich ist das die
Schuldenstreichung von Ländern des
globalen Südens damit sich diese Länder
leisten können zum Beispiel fossile
Rohstoffe im Boden lassen zu können weil
sie eigentlich nur darauf momentan
gezwungen werden diese Rohstoffe zu
extrahieren um ihre Auslandsschulden zu
zahlen Schulden die teilweise schon
mehrfach zurückbezahlt worden sind wenn
man die Zinszahlungen in Betracht sieht
die gezahlt worden sind und wir sind
eine Gruppe die vor allem in der
ArbeiterInnen und auch Gewerkschaften
der zentrale Rolle spielen weil diese
diejenigen sind die tatsächlich auch
eine politische Macht haben können eine
demokratische macht und ihre Rechte sich
durch legitimen gesellschaftlichen
Protest auch erkämpft haben und da ist
eben etwas da waren wir ja noch nicht da
dass wir Christian Lindner Herr Lindner
am Montag einen kleinen Besuch
abgestattet haben weil Herr Lindner uns
mir persönlich tatsächlich auch für zwei
Monaten das Versprechen abgegeben hat
also er hat mir versprochen also Herr
Lindner ist auf sie zugegangen und hat
gesagt nein ich habe die den
demokratischen Weg gewählt und bin zu
den zu der offenen Tür des
Finanzministeriums also Tag der offenen
Tür das Finanzministeriums gegangen und
habe dann Herr Lindner gefragt ob er
beim IWF bei dem Jahrestreffen des IWFs
und der Weltbank das jetzt vor zwei
Wochen stattgefunden hat die Streichung
der Schulden des globalen Südens fordern
würde und er hat einfach mit ja
geantwortet und dieses Versprechen ist
aber eines was er gebrochen hat er hat
es nicht gemacht und genau deswegen
bitte Lindner gesprochen um jetzt mal
auf den Punkt zu kommen ja ja
hat er sich gefreut wenigstens bei so
schönen Frauen
tatsächlich haben wir genau daneben die
das heutzutage Sexismus
also linda hat mit ihm schon gesprochen
von Neubau gesprochen er nimmt sie auf
jeden Fall dem Thema an nicht auf die
Art und Weise wie wir es gerne hätten
okay und er er sagt ach ja wir machen
das ja schon alles wir sind auf der
gleichen Seite aber das stimmt einfach
nicht das was er macht ist eine
nachhaltige schuldenrestrukturierung das
ist nicht das gleiche wie in der
schuldenernulierung des globalen Südens
und genau diesen Unterschied finden wir
ihm ganz gerne noch mal persönlich
machen werden nach Frau Wagner möchte
gerne noch mal zu Ihnen kommen laden Sie
sie doch noch mal ein das würde uns sehr
freuen für die dem